all right this you really have to see to
believe i'm going to play video for you
today
of really a servant serving his master
that's really what this is and the
servant is a sitting u.s senator and the
master is a fox news propagandist i'm
talking about ted cruz and tucker
carlson if you haven't been following
the story
it is really incredible what this says
about the current state of political
affairs the current state of society and
the republican party
um wednesday last wednesday uh we were
you know it was the the anniversary of
uh january we were it was the eve of the
anniversary of january 6th
and in a senate hearing ted cruz said
we were approaching the anniversary of a
violent terrorist attack on the capital
and
a lot of people on the right
didn't like ted cruz calling what
happened on january 6 2021 a terrorist
attack and tucker carlson didn't like it
and apparently
tucker carlson and ted cruz started
texting about it
and ted cruz ended up appearing on the
tucker carlson program
to apologize i am going to play for you
a sitting u.s senator having to go on
and do a maya culpa to the person who is
really in charge apparently
tucker carlson and this shouldn't
surprise us hannity was giving trump
advice and in contact with trump telling
him what to do
um what does it say what does it say
when a republican senator answers to a
right-wing media propagandist let's take
a look at this so we played this tape
for you last time we were surprised by
it we prefaced it by saying every
conservative appreciates ted cruz
because he's one of the smartest and
most articulate people in the congress
and he's conservative
but he referred publicly to what
happened on january 6th is quote a
violent terror attack here it is
we are approaching a solemn anniversary
this week
and it is an anniversary of a violent
terrorist attack on the capitol where we
saw the men and women of law enforcement
demonstrate incredible courage
incredible bravery
risk their lives
to defend the men and women who serve in
this capital
really not controversial now many will
focus on none of them were charged with
terrorism
it's very common that people aren't
charged with literally the thing that we
colloquially say they did there's still
a debate is it or isn't it terrorism but
this it's really not a big deal what he
said
and look at tucker's concerned face and
ted cruz has been a bad boy and he's
gonna have to apologize
senator cruz was game enough to come on
tonight we appreciate that he joins us
now senator thanks so much for coming on
so i guess what i mean there are a lot
of dumb people in the congress you're
not one of them i think you're smarter
than i am
and you never use words
carelessly um and yet you called this a
terror attack
when by no definition was it a terror
attack that's a lie
you told that lie on purpose and i'm
wondering why you did
well tucker thank you for having me on
when you aired your episode last night i
sent you a text shortly thereafter and
said listen i'd like to go on because
sir i'd like to apologize pretty please
the way i phrased things yesterday it it
was sloppy and and it was frankly dumb
yeah i don't buy that whoa whoa whoa
whoa i don't buy that for a look the
teacher that's not a good enough apology
little ted the teacher's gonna demand a
better apology on you a long time since
before you went to the senate you're a
supreme court contender you take words
as seriously as any man who's ever
served in the senate and every words you
repeated that phrase by the way imagine
ted cruz on the supreme court that's a
horror movie do not believe that you use
that accidentally i just don't
it's so tucker as a result of my sloppy
phrasing it's caused a lot of people to
misunderstand what i meant let me tell
you what what i meant to say
what i was referring to are are the
limited number of people who engaged in
violent attacks against police officers
i think you and i both agree that if you
assault a police officer you should go
to jail that's who i was talking about
and the reason the phrasing was sloppy
is i have talked dozens if not hundreds
of times i've drawn a distinction i
wasn't saying that the thousands this is
so pathetic if you watch this and you go
who has the power here
is it the u.s senator or is it the fox
propagandist
it's obviously the fox propagandist the
peaceful protesters supporting donald
trump are somehow terrorists i wasn't
saying the millions of of patriots
across the country supporting president
trump are terrorists and that's what a
lot of people have misunderstood that
kind of wait a second but even your way
but hold on what you just said doesn't
make sense so if somebody assaults a cop
he should be charged and go to jail i
couldn't agree more we have said that
for years
but that person's still not a terrorist
how many people have been charged with
terrorism on january 6th like why'd you
use that word you're playing into the
other side's
characterization that is joe kent ted
cruz has been a bad bad boy just
explained allows them to define an
entire population as foreign combatants
and you know that so why'd you do it so
tucker let me answer you directly the
the reason i use that word for a decade
i have referred to people who violently
assault police officers as terrorists
i've done so over and over and over
again if you look at all the assaults
we've seen across the country i've
called that terrorism over and over
again that being said tucker i agree
with you it was a mistake to say that
yesterday and the reason i know what
i've been bad i've apologized three
times already please we've now had a
year of democrats in the media twisting
words right and trying to say that all
of us are terrorists trying to say
you're a terrorist i'm a terrorist and
so look i talk about a red herring huh
like people who who assault cops and and
i
stand up and defend cops
and
the reason i use that word is that's the
word i've always used for people that
violently attack cops but in this
context i get why people were angry
because we've had a year of the corrupt
corporate media and democrats claiming
anyone who who objected to to the
election fraud and by the way remember
what was happening
can i just ask all that you work in this
i just i guess i just don't believe you
and i mean that with respect because i
have such respect for your you're so
great that this is too stupid for me to
accept acuity and your precision and
i've seen it on display i've covered you
as a reporter i know how you speak
and you have sat there for a year and
watched people use language to distort
the event anyway it goes on from here
you can find the entire thing online
what does it say about society that ted
cruz answers to the right-wing media
propagandist of the day
obviously our elected officials should
answer to us the people we're the ones
who elect them that's not what's going
on here ted cruz is not uh tucker
carlson is not a constituent of ted cruz
this is really an indication of the
power dynamics and ted cruz sort of gets
to use the term colloquially ted cruz
gets cucked by everybody because
remember trump
called ted cruz's wife ugly
and then ted cruz came out and said
trump's great i support trump i love
trump trump trump trump and then now
here he is doing his may could i have
some more porridge please
uh totally subservient totally
subservient to tucker carlson really
interesting uh uh instructive example of
who is actually holding the power in
these dynamics right now if you're
having trouble thinking of what to give
someone as a holiday gift check out our
sponsor shaker and spoon the monthly
cocktail subscription box delivering the
ingredients and recipes for craft
cocktails right to your door they send
you everything you need to make the
cocktails except for the alcohol you
provide that it comes with a really nice
recipe card easy to follow my most
recent shaker and spoon cocktail
creation was called the capri crush it's
a camparian gin drink with spiced orange
grapefruit cordial and dashfire orange
bitters delicious my turned out great i
know nothing about mixing drinks neither
do most of my friends but with my shaker
and spoon cocktails i ended up looking
like i knew something about it which is
good it's very good for my cred
you don't have to go to a crowded bar to
enjoy an excellent cocktail shaker and
spoon lets you do it all at home great
for date nights makes a perfect gift and
you'll get twenty dollars off when you
use the promo code pacman at checkout go
to shakerandspoon.com
pacman and the link is down below